yeah welcome everyone um the thanks for
the introduction this is actually the
name of the company I I'm one of the
partners um we also have the booth come
by first little bit background how did
this talk come about so as Chris
mentioned I am an around at many
conferences so I talked to many data
scientists I talked to many experts I
think this year with the calls for free
conferences I read about like a thousand
proposals for conference talks this
gives me one good perspective on the
experts side but when we work with
clients I also hear their side and where
they are struggling and what they think
they should do and not and this is that
is the perspectives I want to share um
yeah and my first question is whose data
scientists or an expert in - okay and
who's more like in the management or
like organizing project management
position okay welcome you all its yeah
and I see y'all very often sir let's
first start with ya where we do stand
arm the other so let's start with the
data scientist perspective and let's
start with a happy data scientist
perspective so if I speak toward the
happy data scientist they say my work is
appreciated
I can I can live up to my full potential
I am highly trained very likely you're a
curious person who wants to provide
value to your company and solve problems
improve and have a high standard also on
ethics and everything but I also talked
to many data scientists who are not so
happy they work at a big company and
they feel limited to say I'm a data
scientist I can do deep learning I could
do machine learning I have many ideas
but actually I'm tied up I'm I'm working
as an analyst and they're like not not
so happy and taunt because they probably
not heard since I expect it to be more
have more experts in the room I want
have a little bit broader perspective on
what is made probably the managers
expand their perspective here so
actually I found something online how
managers spend their time so of course a
lot of it is administration ah solving
problems collaborating strategy
innovation it's only 10% and developing
people and any achieve stable 7% so you
just see they're busy with many other
things where you maybe say I'm doing
code review or solving barks oh so this
is maybe probably their part here and
also quite interestingly there was also
a survey or how which managers Fink
which skill they will need to success in
the next five years and actually I was
quite surprised the social the people
skills in my opinion very underrated
because I think the biggest problem in
all technology we solve today basically
I think the biggest problem is actually
human interaction in communication and
everybody has the same understanding how
to solve the problems and where we
really want to go I think that's the
main challenge while of course
technology is moving at light speed so
okay how if you Google managers so I
googled oh you cannot read it's um it's
actually who is it it's yeah I googled
AI for managers we get like the typical
pictures my favorite white android robot
this is like like the quite false
perception of AI but it's pretty sad in
culture nowadays but I also googled
replacing managers and this is the other
perspective this is the first hit with
AI technology replacing managers so but
you know there's also tools like also ml
and stuff like that so what about data
scientists replacing data scientists
will a I still a question it's not a
proposal yet according to Google and if
you're a data engineer you like super
lucky
[Music]
but we see there's a lot of buzzwords
the hype promises around and I think
people many people feel like this like
it's like a crazy party you know we're
you know we're actually moving but we
need to do something so let me tell you
a story I recently met an old friend
at the train station so the person was
very excited to tell me about coming
back to the hometown and there's a have
a new position and like top level
management um and we talked hey what are
you doing now and I said yeah we'll data
something among partners with up with
new people and we run critics week is
the data science consultancy we advise
people on data big data and AI and said
oh great AI in my new position I have to
buy AI as well and I was just like okay
context Tom I'm very skilled high it's
like a highly intelligent person it's
not a dummy like and then I just like
thought okay how do I imagine I have to
be by AI so is it optional or am struc
then cut a piece so how do you buy AI in
2014 and but we talk longer and me we
are a company also understood what the
real problem was that in the company
which had to be addressed and of course
we solved it and I want to share some of
how we solved it because a big part is
actually understanding what the problem
is what the challenges are and get a
better and honest perspective on things
on how to operate so let's start with
the definition data literacy is the
ability to collect manage evaluate and
apply data in a critical manner so if
you're in a data scientist you an expert
this is basically all you know you know
tons of stuff you go to conferences you
have a lot of import you're a creative
person you have many ideas how to solve
and very likely if I talk to my mom or
myself I like to solve problems actually
so I know a lot
and of course I always try to be
transparent with my work and I
approaches so I like to share okay this
is the background this is how it works
this is probably the reason I give many
talks but also if you talk to you please
always think don't try to explain
everything just explain what they need
to know remember keep it to the point
you know this if you're from Germany you
know all these two guys these two like
the mouse and the elephant they'll
explain it in a simple way and let me
take you to data here there's like four
levels of data we have data collection
you have to manage the data we have data
evaluation and then we finally have the
application which is like the nice part
with all the machine learning everything
so on now let's just like walk through
here what has somebody in management or
on a decision maker have to understand
actually about this does he or he or she
or them have to understand actually data
collection know everything yeah the data
is collected right it's works that's all
they have to care about what about so no
so what about data management people
work in enterprises every other job
usually you work with experts and people
who know how to do things of course data
management can be complicated but if you
know the data is being managed probably
in a good fashion and redundant fashion
and all you need depending on your needs
let's manage that's it that's the key
message yeah it's been managed know if
it comes to data evaluation it's not
that simple they didn't basically we can
pin it down like to these six parts we
have data tools if data analysis we have
interpretation and understanding with
data visualization we have presenting
data in an oral way so this is not the
same as the visualization and we have
data-driven decision-making and which
parts actually somebody has to
understand better too
make a decision I think the data tools
the tools don't matter it's they are
matter to us we want to have great tools
when we program and solve problems but
it's it's irrelevant which tools
actually are used to solve things we
have data analysis we need to know have
some knowledge about this very important
this interpretation and understanding of
the data what can we do with it
bethe realization is always nice but
actually it's more important how can we
present the data in in like a
presentation how can I explain it to
somebody just maybe in a meeting or a
phone call without Seabourn and all the
cool tools we have and also it's also of
course important how to make a
data-driven the data-driven decision
making process oh so basically a mixer
but we see basically data evaluation is
there the first part we have to dig a
little deeper in some ways and what
about data application this is basically
the most talked I mean this is the most
talked part aid application and this is
where all the work is actually what most
of the work is let's look here we have
data ethics data citation they visit a
ssin if you don't know it is like if you
cite from for example scientific data
from somewhere else the the data culture
data sharing this is more like sharing
data between your peers critical
thinking and the elevating process this
is evaluating the decisions and if you
look here of course data is super
important you have to understand how you
work with the data
Dyess datasets I think we have a lot of
the heard about this at the conference
and previous conference also in the
keynote yesterday it's important but
maybe not the most important data
culture is important critical thinking
is actually what people trust the
experts to do the critical thinking so
you have to know this critical thinking
in wall blood that's the short message
here so that's what needs to be no data
citation is irrelevant the data is just
like there also like the sharing how you
share the data is not relevant for the
decision-maker and but the evaluating
decisions how
but that's basically the outcome bets
the predictions that everything of
course this has to be understood people
are but you see tackling down maybe from
everything I put here on the slides
maybe you have to get other people in
your team or a decision maker maybe only
on board with like ten twenty percent
okay so here we go just in short I just
want to point to this um also if you
talk in teams or companies or with
clients there are different
personalities in the field and I think
Peter Baumgartner he works in MLP he
gave a talk at Spacey arrow earlier this
year here in Berlin it's referring arey
down to these six personalities you can
also run while running projects with
them and I just want to show like for
example let's show off Sarah who just
wants to do a I he she stereotyped it a
little in a very funny way just look it
up later I think this is very useful
input because there's these different
types of interests here and I think he
narrowed it down really good of course
the decision maker also has to know it's
not the IT department you have to talk
to we are not doing an IT project I the
IT department of course will operate
everything we produce it but at first
data science and AI is research and
development now once we go to production
we have to involve the IT department or
do get resources to do to research but
we need to have an open space and an
open mind to to to address the problems
to bring the value to the clients or to
the company you work with and and this
is very often overlooked they see ok
yeah ok its data its programming ok
let's talk to the IT department the
department in many big enterprises the
IT departments actually just like mostly
configuring tools from other companies
it's not they're probably not even super
capable of programming maybe there's
just some basic sales but basically they
operate more some misperceptions one
misperceptions also are Biggers better
so I just buy the Hadoop cluster and
then I'm set up for the next 10 years
and I
also like eyelets by Watson and we set
up with all the knowledge I mean but
that's it's it's also say okay we don't
need the big resources we can we should
invest probably in other areas and
another misperception is like a data
Lake because this is like also like nice
pictures data lakes we like aha nice
Clear Lake it's not I think this is the
data Lake for example it's a complex
system which involves many other system
basically is more like a thought concept
then a nice lake you can just like pull
it out the data out so these are like
things you have to point out very often
um I see we are confront I see ourselves
confronted that the problem is seems
just to be simple to the pier we talk to
or person we talk to you is because
there's no experience so you hear all
the hype and I said yeah yeah it is it's
easy and we just drove deep learning at
it and we'll solve it and we have to
point out no we should use classical
statistical methods first because they
are stable they're proven and we can
explain the outcome deep learning we can
out and but this is very often so this
is very often you need to you need to
stand up for this and say no we have
simple methods to use this we don't need
the latest and fanciest tech just
because you read about it of course it's
very important to look into this but
it's not the first thing to look at and
the other thing is also I like senior
management maybe say oh we've all seen
this before it's just like a hype and
actually they're right I did some
research
I have MIT technology review has all
past issues back to 1895 I guess online
in the archive of the PDF if you're
subscriber so I actually for a talk and
never did I had another project like but
I saw while I was looking at the old
issues I saw stuff like this so in 1998
we have can computers create literature
okay oh I just gave a talk last year at
Pilate eval in about text literature
like not literature but producing text
so they I am now
that wasn't that successful what about
beyond artificial intelligence in one
year later and one then in 1987 we see
how to keep mature industries innovative
well it sounds like very much like
electrifying automotive nowadays and
also other issues like automation in
1985 there was also a lot of interest in
the industries there was a lot of
automation going on also like agile lean
management Caban this goes back to the
80s this is not invented by computer or
like IT and tech actually this comes
from production industry we just think
we're like super cool because we know
agile and lean no it's old concepts and
also like this I thought I was really
funny and from 1986 after 25 years
artificial intelligence has failed to
live up to his promise ok and but no but
also since 1999 in 1988 we know don't
believe the hype but I think we have to
look at the pattern here because with ai
ai histories in all 70 years so we have
to see there's a constant progress and
challenges and things to solve so we see
we see there's progress here so it's
it's probably you also see sometimes
wave golden age dark wave the ups and
downs so maybe deep learning will hit
another bound soon we don't know maybe
not
that's nice recently I saw Andrew kappa
no not Andrew Kapoor Thea customer of
Hesperus where I grew up
Kasparov was a rockstar Kasparov was the
best chess player in the world so and he
gave a talk recently Lausanne and he was
on stage and he actually he played about
to come against the computing all these
people here who basically built the
theater good groundwork for what we work
on computers today said once the machine
can beat a human in chess they take over
they have won so ok Kasparov
he was the brains last stand in the 90s
I remember that we still live computers
still have taken over the world
not say we see also like a progress here
so of course all the stuff from the D
point is better than the players here
um it's that's quite it very interesting
but I think this is the best point he
made actually he was citing Pablo
Picasso because said computers are
useless they only give us answers and
let me also introduce you how we
basically address like getting literacy
a little bit better in the head of coins
and decision makers so this is now about
demos and magic and one really good
approach from go D etre driven actually
was I Istanbul across you know Vincent
he also just gave a talk earlier today
he's from Amsterdam and they did a game
where basically the data scientists have
to play and create value for the company
there's a blog post about it just read
about it um we did Jupiter notebooks
with the Titanic Titanic is super boring
for everybody who's here in data science
computer science but think Titanic is
still super instructive if you you are
new in the field or if you just curious
how this works so I put an executive
summary here tied attic Danna
instructive and sample you can learn
about how to make predictions how to
make bad predictions like for example
hey all the women died all the men and
no other women survived all the men die
we already have 80% accuracy we all know
that if you know you know now and this
is very expected about the main
expertise and it's a really nice example
people can just everybody understands
Titanic and so it's very nice to also
present this in just like one hour with
not too much code to management people
or some like this at a time there was a
little mermaid named siren who lived
with her stepmother under the sea she
didn't get to go out of the sea like any
other okay this is a synthesized voice
which was trained on charcoal tron tool
and what's the main KOA takeaway here
it's not what we can do speech synthesis
nowadays no the main takeaway is I'm
trained it on this MacBook in the GPU in
nine days of training it can read
English text without cloud service it's
probably not the super production ready
but this is like come on this is this is
no budget for some output like this it's
not a million budget by Mac pokers yeah
maybe well s plus the time
and then also you can explain this is
scalable and you have an instant
application like reading text and many
people don't know this they think on it
takes all a long time yeah this is what
I would skip this is just like this is
the network I would explain it to you
but takes it just here the summary here
is high quality data plus a cleverly
designed neural net produces this output
at a very reasonable budget the same
well similar I won't go deep here is
like data signal on predictions so
actually did you know like psytrance
first this is actually just like a
prediction or this picture using this
style
it's a convolutional net work you can
just like we simplify the data and apply
another style arm speed up here a bit so
this is like like a short video how
network trains but it's very instructive
to see people oh I okay this is how the
network is learning and how it's
flickering you see we're just like
evening things out it's people can feel
how it works people don't want to read
math or hear too much PowerPoint stuff
and you can explain things take longer
this is just like some example say hey
all fancy style transform or likes know
everything in my slides is that ones for
fancy fancy fancy but what I also like
to show people it does not really work
all the time so EFT is like it's just
like a picture from the beach but you
will see like this hull here this is not
working well we can reason what why so
it's a very good explanation people can
see you just not throw a I added and it
will always work because one great thing
is we have a lot of open research papers
plus the internet plus the news so
there's at least one new news about
awesome research is somewhere found this
you can do this with a I am will change
the world so but the summary here is
papers demonstrating several impressive
findings but following progress is
important but only 95 percent of the
research actually survives in production
as some other reasons so it's not all
you read about will actually work out in
the field and also people should be
aware about adversary attacks ah because
the network is not just like better like
a perfect machine actually not so
perfect this is like
example how some to researchers fool you
Lou here also because just like of
having this picture in front he's not
recognized as a person where we actually
see we think like object detections and
into identifying people's basically
really soft and scalable but it's not
it's like just take this picture and you
go look it up in video so the summary
here is new networks on not none are not
perceiving reality as we humans do
premiere networks may be fool and they
are better and fast at many things but
they are not really good in transferring
knowledge as we do so I think to
actually to solve it and how to get it
going I think to sum it up I think it's
important to team up to establish an
open honest and respectful communication
culture so I sing and I very often now
tell the clients come come to a Python
conference see the communication culture
the respectful communication culture we
have established because the Python
community I think one thing it makes us
great is you can talk to an austere Amin
ah you can talk to a web developer we
have many different perspectives and to
look at things and very often reach out
to astronomers it for example
effectively view tricky questions I can
maybe have a solution because
astronomers deal with big data for for a
very very long time it's not just the
Internet
it's it's very open to downtown don't
expect to this to work overnight with
one meeting it's all about trust it's
respect very often I see a physicist or
somebody had a client um and I probably
know we should improve the coding skills
something but take take the time and
take the space to communicate it and
then for example part of my job or or
offering insight to train enable people
how bring how can we bring ideas through
production how can we experiment how can
we baby make all this fly and yeah if
you like the pictures in these slides
because they were all made with die
transfer that's why it's really easy to
take all the pop-culture pictures just
so processed is transfer
it's here so also we had some people
happy people here you are booth it's
just in the main hall we have a
photobook so you can just like go there
and take a picture send it to yourself
have fun with friends and yeah thank you
very much we do have time for questions
[Music]
Rachel thanks for your talk what types
of resources or additional learning do
you generally suggest to managers that
you work with if people want to learn
more I think I think it's very important
to give them an oversight this is the
technology this is where we come from
also like to like to give them better
definitions because for example there's
big data what is actually big data many
people think with 2 gigabytes this is
big data we say no no it's not well try
to not to put it in figures just like
I'm always trying to almost like
establish other pictures so big data is
you basically if the handling of the
data is a problem before if you don't
have if you can save it on a drive or in
your Center it's not a problem I think
it's very good to give them an overview
and always for example if you prepare a
training for this we always keep the
schedule flexible because you never know
what the real interest is because I
always ask hey what are your real
problems you want to solve we where are
your pains which where's where how can
we help
basically so and then usually during the
training the insurance move a bit and
then we go a little bit more into
machine learning space or we address
deep learning or we very often say ok we
can just solve it the staffs actually
and and very often we see ok the
suggestion is very oft ok you have to
establish a better communication culture
you you're facing data silos and your
company arm and we we show how we can
solve it with open source so we always
try to push for open source solutions as
well which
in Germany not that simple because it's
still a new thing for me and for
enterprises yeah that's that's that's
how we tackle a thank you for the talk
so we experienced that often there's a
translation problem between data
scientists and managers data scientists
obviously knows know a lot of the data
and techniques but managers have a
difficult time coming up with how data
science can help them in their daily
work and then they come up with things
like what is the revenue of this
customers this customer in two years if
brexit comes yes ideas that are just not
feasible and so we're thinking about
educating them and and we don't have
such a good experience with with your
idea of giving them the Titanic data set
because if you make it easy enough and
and then they they just have a good time
and I think all this is cool but they
still don't understand what data sense
can't do which thinks of now so I would
like to have your opinion on educating
them more about the concepts and the
structure yeah
don't really do hands-on data science
actually like we don't it depends it
depends on the team and and and how
Pierre valuate first who are all peers
is somebody with programming skills no
programming so we do no programming and
I was simplifying with the Titanic
example before here the main message was
okay it's boring to us but probably no
to other people but of course and the
rest is basically flexible it depends on
on the group we work with so sometimes
you just need to explain the Titanic
example and you see okay there's other
other opportunities but very often we
come back okay how's your data pipeline
how's your data stored is the data even
accessible which is like I would say the
majority of the cases yeah we have all
these ideas in our head but we cannot
make it happen before we have data
pipelines production ready and
accessible in the company and but
usually we don't try to go too deep into
tech and code because many people are
just
afraid of cold because we are used like
even you can like to think about just
show a JSON file which is like super
simple data structure just joy to your
parents and maybe so what is this this
is just like gibberish this is just like
random characters on an empty page we
very often forget because we scan these
patterns JSON code and it says something
to us and even very good code is like
just gibberish for if you're not used to
it um we have time for one last question
all right thanks for the talk is great I
recognize a lot of things you mentioned
I wonder do you have any experience with
like so so you're in data science or
what we can do is for for those
businesses make predictions and all that
kind of things I always a very hard time
explaining that many of the things we
find are not causal relationships
however as a follow-up they do want to
take action using the models okay but
how and and they always hope to see like
okay if we can like tweet this button
then this will happen but often the data
does not allow you to make these kind of
conclusions so you have any experience
with it now yeah actually it's we try to
it's it's it's it's always like it's how
can we say it's a lactic it's like it a
balance because very often we have
Facebook with clients as well they have
big expectations of course as if they
hire us to to help them build the models
and hit work of course we want to
deliver but sometimes there's nothing to
deliver it's just like not enough the
data call he's not good enough it's it's
it's not we cannot resign we just like
we are just honest and I think another
example can be so many people I want to
use the latest tech so person yeah we
needed kubernetes cluster then yeah we
just like prototyping where's the
kubernetes cluster for if we go to a
production and if there's many many
machines we probably will use it and
sometimes it's not easy even for me as a
senior person to stand up because of
course you want to also win the client
you want to work with the people and and
you want the business but on the other
hand its we'd rather say okay no we say
that's this is how we do it this is how
our perspective you don't need this um
we can smart smaller
or your advises and yeah and very often
- honesty is trust-building and then you
can have to follow up business as well
and if for us that's basically how we
see also our businesses I mean if the
clients just wants to have the hype and
have some results to present some
something you say this program it's not
a good fit for us it doesn't mean then
we'd rather not work for the client
because we want to our mission is to
enable them that's how we see and then
you sometimes have to say no although
even if it's hard Thank You Alexandra
thank you very much
[Applause]